[موسيقى]
فين مش شايفك
يا لهوي ايه ده
[تصفيق]
الارتجال بيعلم ازاي ارتجل وافضل في نفس
القصه بتاعتي واقدر ازود عليها بناء يزود
للقصه
قال لي بنتي اهم حاجه في الاستوري اكثر من
الكوميديا الاستوري تبقى قويه الاستوري
تبقى حلوه ده بيبسط اكتر
والنهارده
[تصفيق]
باسم بلدي واقول حكايتي كده كده لو انت
عايز تبقى كوميديان في حاجات تعملها ممكن
تعمل بتاعك تشبع رغبات وتشبع غرورك في في
الضحك ممكن تعمل ستاندوت بس في رجالي احنا
بنحاول نتعامل كجروب
حبيبتي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
التمثيل عن الارتجال في الحته بتاعه
التلقائيا الارتجال بيعلمك ازاي تسمعي
كويس وازاي تبقي فيه كونكشن متواصل بينك
وبين الممثل اللي قدامك وفي الحته بتاعه
العمل الجماعي ازاي الناس تخلي بالها على
بعض في المشهد وازاي ان احنا نلحق ازاي
ننقذ بعض من غير ما نبقى متفقين على اي
حاجه وان احنا نبقى متواصلين يعني عامه
بتتعلمي تاخذي ريسك بتتعلميه تبقي دائما
ذهنك حاضر عارفه تقولي ايه
كريتف هو الارتجال يعتبر حاجه سهله جدا
لان هي انت بتكوني انسانه حقيقيه جدا وانت
يعني احنا ارتجاليه احنا فريق واحد لكن
بنبقى زي فريق متعدد الشخصيات لكن كيان
واحد كلنا بنمثل نفس الشيء كلنا بنساعد
بعض
[ضحك]
لو حد عنده حاجه جواه مش بيعرف يطلعها بره
في الحياه اللي بره العمليه بتاعته لا هو
بيجي بيطلعها هنا في ارتجال والارتجال
برضه بيعودك على انه ما فيش صح وغلط هو اي
حاجه بتطلع منك هو ده
انا بحبها فارتجاليه كانت بالنسبه لي
المكان اللي هلعب فيه كل الكاريز اللي
ممكن اتخيله وما كنتش اتخيلك كمان
البنطلون
[تصفيق]